BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: Welcome.
Thanks for joining us today.
We're going to be talking
about analyzing distributed
traces to find performance
bottlenecks in your system.
I'm Bryan Zimmerman, product
manager with Google Cloud.
FRANCIS BOGSANYI:
And I'm Francis.
I work on distributed
tracing in Shopify,
and I'm also a maintainer
of OpenTelemetry Ruby.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: In order
to speak about performance
troubleshooting,
first, let's talk
about performance problems.
These are problems with the
latency or compute utilization
of your services,
and these are things
that will impact your user's
experience of your product
and your bottom line.
These are often
difficult because there
is no clear error or event
that has caused the issue.
Instead, they may be
an optimization that
has existed in your
system for a while,
or there could be a
problem that has creeped up
or is otherwise buried.
FRANCIS BOGSANYI: Performance
problems in large distributed
systems can be
surprising, and causality
is often missing or buried
in other telemetry signals.
A couple of real examples we
found with distributed tracing
in Shopify, an RPC was
executed twice unintentionally
due to a quirk in the
network architecture.
And volume in memcache that grew
in size without anyone noticing
and then suddenly became
popular during a flash sale,
exhausting network
link capacity.
Both of these jumped up really
quickly from trace data.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN:
Today we're going
to be highlighting a couple
key tools from the cloud
observability toolset.
First is Cloud Trace.
This is a distributed
tracing tool
that is particularly useful
for latency scenarios,
but it's also useful
in any scenario
where a downstream service is
affecting upstream behavior.
Then there's Cloud Profiler.
This is a continuous
profiling application
that helps you find exactly
what part of your code
is responsible for an issue.
These exist as part
of a larger toolset.
This toolset is based off the
same planet scale platform
that powers Google's internal
observability, so you
know it's been battle tested.
In addition, it comes with
zero day configuration,
out of the box for
key Google services.
So for those who
aren't familiar,
let's talk about what
distributed tracing is.
Here's an example
application architecture.
Your users may communicate
with the front end
through load balancers.
That will communicate in
turn to multiple back ends,
including databases.
However, today,
your application is
more likely to look like this,
many small micro services
working together
for a common goal.
This is a great
application architecture
that becomes very
difficult to troubleshoot.
Distributed tracing
allows you to understand
exactly how the
request has moved
through this environment,
which definitely simplifies
troubleshooting scenarios.
FRANCIS BOGSANYI:
At Shopify, we're
often known for our devotion
to our core monolith.
In reality though, there is
an increasingly large set
of services orbiting
that monolith,
and performance is impacted
by all services involved
in processing their request,
including third-party services.
Distributed tracing
provides visibility
into the performance of
these increasingly deep,
distributed systems that is
almost impossible to achieve
any other way.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: Next, let's
review, continuous profiling.
Continuous profiling
helps specifically
with what happens in
a particular service.
The intent is to identify the
method or section of code that
is contributing to the issue or
the source of the optimization.
Cloud Profiler takes
profiles of your application
at every function
call in a sampled way.
This means it's perfectly
safe to run in production.
These profiles are laid
out on a flame graph where
it's visually extremely
easy to understand
how these functions
play together
and where the cause
of an issue is.
When we talk to customers,
the troubleshooting process
typically follows these steps.
You start with an issue and
refine that issue as much
as possible using
the metrics you have,
then you try to identify the
service that's responsible.
This is particularly important
for distributed systems.
Further refining to the
method or part of your code
where the issue
exists is extremely
important for efficient
troubleshooting.
And then finally, looking at
deep information such as logs
and debugging tools,
help you come up
with a viable
hypothesis for what
might be causing the issue.
This is, of course, required
before any resolution can
be attempted, which needs
to be pushed and confirmed
using the same metrics that
identified the problem for you.
FRANCIS BOGSANYI: In
practice, we can treat traces
as contextualized logs.
Typically, trace
instrumentation initially
focuses on the edges
in a service graph
where communication
happens between services.
Performance problems
show up as large spans
with large gaps
between child spans,
but we don't know
what's going on.
So the hypothesis
part of our process
involves incrementally
filling in those empty spaces
by adding instrumentation
to our code
until we gain some
insight into what
is different about this path.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN:
Now, let's see this
in action using Google
Cloud's observability suite
of products.
We're going to show
you a series of demos
on our demo application
online boutique.
We'll take you from problem
to service to method
to hypothesis starting with
identifying and refining
the problem.
FRANCIS BOGSANYI:
We're going to show
how to use Cloud Monitoring
to find and refine
the problem you're
attempting to investigate.
As you can see here,
we already have
an incident related to latency.
You can see from looking
at the policy details
that we've actually
defined this alert
to be 90th percentile latency
sustained for one minute.
This kind of alert
configuration ensures
that only real problems
generate alerts and wake up
our on-call tech.
To understand the
problem further,
we're going to open up one of
our pre-configured dashboards,
in this case, the
Performance dashboard.
We can see a definite
spike in latency
in our server latency heat map.
This can be shown both from the
aggregate percentile lines as
well as the distribution itself.
Let's drill into the
inflection point.
At this point, we definitely
understand what to investigate,
which is GRPC server latency.
Next, we're to use
distributed tracing
to understand the source
of that latency spike.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: With the
problem well understood,
it's time to identify
the service where
the issue most likely exists.
FRANCIS BOGSANYI: To investigate
the cause of this latency,
we're going to use a new
feature called Example Traces.
This allows us to
overlay sampled traces
onto the latency heat map
from within the monitoring
dashboard.
Here we can drill into
the specific requests
that generated those metric
data points of interest.
In this instance,
it's quite obvious
to see that most of
the time is spent
during the getProduct operation.
We can check other requests to
see if it's a similar pattern,
and indeed, it is.
To validate our
hypothesis, let's check
some 50th percentile traces
from before the spike.
To investigate
this further, we're
going to open Cloud Trace.
Here we can further
dig into the traces
that exemplify this problem.
This allows us to filter for
additional details, including
label values and see
the trend over time.
As you can see, the
visual representation
of your entire request
that trace provides
allows you to easily see
where the problem is.
In this case, as
mentioned earlier,
it seems to be in the product
catalog service getProduct
operation, which
is done repeatedly
and has been taking
a much longer time
than looking at traces
from before the spike.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN:
Kellyanne is going
to show you how you
can use Google Cloud
Profiler to identify
where in the code
this issue or
optimization can be found.
KELLYANNE: Now, we will
use Google Cloud Profiler
to investigate which
functions in your service code
could be slowing it down.
The default view
of profiler shows
you a plane graph representation
of your service profile.
In this plane graph, we
can get a bird's eye view
of where the service is
spending most of its time.
Here we have selected the
product catalog service,
and we are specifically
looking at the CPU
time for this service.
Just by looking at
the plane graph,
we can understand
that most of the time
is spent in this stack,
which is the GRPC
receiver for this service.
Walking down this
stack, we can see
that POS catalog is where you
are spending most of your time.
Opening the top function's table
and sorting by that total time,
we can confirm that
68% of the total time
is spent in POS catalog.
Walking down the
stack some more,
we can see that this time
is spent in actually JSON
Unmarshaling function.
So this should be the first
focus of our optimization
efforts.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: To form
a viable hypothesis,
we're going to use
logging and debugging
tools included with
Google Cloud observability
suite of products.
FRANCIS BOGSANYI: We're going
to jump to the related logs
for this particular trace.
In the previous demo, we found
that the cause of the problem
was most likely within the
product catalog service.
To dig into this
further, we're going
to filter to that particular
Kubernetes resource pod.
This can be done easily
at the click of a button.
And immediately,
via the histogram,
it's obvious that
something has changed
around the time of this issue.
Let's jump to the
start of this problem
to see what's happening.
And similar to what we
saw within Profiler,
this service is successfully
parsing the product catalog
very, very often and
repeatedly, certainly
more than it was previous
to the issue starting.
This confirms our
hypothesis that the problem
is related to parsing
of the product catalog.
To further dig into this,
we can inspect the messages
from our logs, correlate that
with the behavior of our code
via debugger and our IDE.
Cloud Debugger
allows you to inspect
what's happening within
your running application
by injecting snapshots
or log points
whenever you like in your code.
We'll show this in action by
going to our currency service,
and let's take a
snapshot at line 155.
What we can see here on
the right-hand side is,
instantly, we're able to see
details of the local variables
at the time the
snapshot was taken.
Now, what if you only
want to take that snapshot
in certain circumstances?
Maybe I'm chasing an issue
with only a certain region
or a certain user.
Well, you can add conditions.
These are written
in the language
of the code that
you're debugging
or expressions, which
will print certain aspects
of your application
as you write them.
Now, maybe I don't want a
snapshot that occurs once,
but I want to on a recurring
basis take a log point.
Well, you can do that.
You can inject log
points that will
be run every time the code
is hit, not just once.
And again, these can be written
with any condition, written
in the language of the
code you're debugging,
and with any message.
The editor allows you
to do this easily.
You can write whatever log point
you want as long as it will not
affect the writing byte code and
it meets certain memory and CPU
footprint requirements.
These features allow
you to understand
what's happening within your
actual production application.
This can be a game
changer when it
comes to understanding
and debugging issues
that only happen on production.
It also makes it much easier for
operators, SREs, or developers
to troubleshoot issues
without having to wait
for long deployment cycles.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: The
demos you've just seen
gives you a highly
guided experience
to troubleshoot
performance problems
using Google Cloud's
observability suite
of products, but sometimes
the answer is not that simple.
There isn't a single
request or even
a set of logs that shows you
exactly where the problem is.
This is where understanding
the system and its requests
in aggregate is
extremely important.
In order to help
with this, we've
recently released a
feature where traces
can be exported to BigQuery.
Any label that you send
into your span data
gets written as
unique columns, which
makes searching even easier.
This allows you to use
the power of BigQuery
to perform custom analysis.
It also allows
you to retain data
for much longer than
the included 30 days.
Now, I'm going to
hand things over
to Francis, who's
going to explain
how this kind of aggregate
analysis is done at Shopify.
FRANCIS BOGSANYI: At
Shopify, we use the query
for aggregate trace analysis.
I'm going to gratefully
demonstrate how we do that.
Firstly though, why do we
need aggregate analysis?
The typical approach
to trace analysis
is to search for
interesting traces,
perhaps by service
and time frame
and either incrementally
refine our search until we
have a smallish set
of traces to look at
or hope that the 1,000 or so
traces return to representative
of what we're looking for
and start clicking randomly.
By viewing a few
random traces, we're
hoping that anything
interesting we
find is representative of
the larger set of traces.
Using a tool like the
query, however, we
can analyze all the
traces in the set
and allow it to surface
interesting information.
We still often want to
look at complete traces
to provide more context,
but we'll have confidence
that the traces we look at
will be truly representative.
If we want to use BigQuery
for trace analysis,
we have to get the trace
data into it somehow.
There's a couple of
ways you could do this.
For example, at Shopify, we have
a slightly complex ingestion
pipeline using the OpenTelemetry
Collector, pops-up GCS,
and batch upload to be queried.
Google Cloud Trace
provides a simpler option
with Trace Exports.
The scheme in the
Cloud Trace used
for trace data in the query is
determined by the trace V2 API
definition of span.
So it stores one span per
row with nested records
for span attributes.
Shopify schema is
similar but based
on the OpenTelemetry protocol
definition of span instead.
If we're performing in-depth
analysis of something
relatively constrained,
our first step
is always to extract
the data we're
interested in into
its own table.
This can drastically reduce
query costs, leverage
the query cache, and generally,
increase responsiveness.
In this example,
we're going to analyze
synthetic load generated
against the test shop.
Almost all of the units of work
performed by our core monolith,
whether request or
background jobs,
are scoped to a single shop.
So we always tag
requests in jobs spans
with the [INAUDIBLE] shop ID.
We know the time interval
for the load test and the ID
that the test shop.
Our table is partitioned
by start time,
so we specify that
as our first photo.
We're doing a bunch
of analysis that
has no obvious partitioning
or clustering characteristics,
so we don't bother specifying
clustering or partitioning
for our destination table.
We use the subquery to
identify trace IDs that
meet our requirements
and then copy
all those spans from those
traces to the new table.
Here we've extracted about
8 gigabytes and 13 and 1/2
million spans from a
22 terabyte partition.
This significantly reduces
the working set for analysis.
Let's start our analysis
with some basic queries
to figure out the services
involved in read metrics.
It doesn't get much
simpler than this.
This gives us a list of
the services involved.
Read metrics are a
little more complicated.
Let's focus on one service,
the storefront renderer.
We'll count requests per minute,
filtering to the service,
and looking only
at surface spans.
The key piece is here at
truncating the stop time
and grouping and ordering
by the truncated stop time.
We can see around 45,000
RPM over the first half
of the test, followed by a
dip, and then an increase
to around 175,000 RPM
in the second half.
I should note here that
we're done sampling traces
in the collectors, so we
saw a significant multiple
of this request
rate, but this serves
to show the general
shape of the load.
Note that we can trivially
adjust this query
to return a second request rate.
The big query console is
great for trying our queries,
but once we start building
queries like this,
we want to easily
visualize the results.
There are many
tools to integrate
with a query including Google
Sheets and Data Studio.
At Shopify, we use Mode
Analytics for data analysis.
In Mode, we build our
SQL queries separately,
and then we can access the data
sets by name in a notebook.
Plotting our query
results is pretty trivial.
Here are the plots from
our earliest queries
and from a similar
query for request rate
to our core [INAUDIBLE] list.
To calculate duration
as a distribution,
we bucketize by minute and
compute each percentile
over each minute.
We represent duration
in microseconds,
so here I'm converting
to milliseconds.
And here's what that
looks like as a plot.
Before we drill in further,
one more high-level perspective
we might like is
the relationship
between the services involved
and the relative volume
of traffic.
This is variously called a
service graph, or service map.
Here's what that looks
like in this example.
The key pieces we need to know
are the source destination
and request count for
each edge in the graph.
The query required for this
is a little more complicated,
but there's really two
things going on here.
The first part of
this query considers
requests that are
represented by a single span.
These are typically
database or cache queries
where we only have the
instrumentation on the client
side.
The other set of requests
we're interested in have
two sides, so we grab the
set of [INAUDIBLE] spans
with the tracing span IDs
and the set of service spans
with the trace and
parent span IDs
and then join them
on the trace ID
where the parent span ID at the
server is the client span ID.
Grouping gives us the request
count along each edge.
So let's go deeper and
break down request counts
and durations by component.
For request count, we query the
Rows Control, attribute as well
and group by both start
time and the controller.
In some cases, the
attribute is missing,
so we replace it with unknown.
Plotting this gives
us a request rate
for the different controllers.
Breaking down the
duration by controller
is slightly more gnarly.
I built this query in
the BigQuery console
by trial and error, and
a data analyst somewhere
is probably having
a fit watching
me try to play one on TV.
Regardless, some query extracts
a start time, controller,
and duration from
the relevant spans,
and then we can keep the
P95 partition by the start
time and controller.
The result is a little obscured
by an outlier controller, which
looks like the
null count control.
We could ignore this
controller in the SQL query,
but it's easier to do
it here with pandas.
This produces a much
clearer breakdown.
Drill downs are also
relatively easy with pandas.
Here we drill down into the
collection's controller.
We can then easily contrast the
duration for this controller
with the request rate
for the controller
from our earlier query.
Now, we might want
to ask where we're
spending time in aggregate in
request to this controller.
Let's start by querying all
the operations performed
during those requests.
We have 26 operations,
which is quite manageable.
We have the expected reticent
MySQL queries and template
parsing and rendering.
Computing the workload
contribution of each operation
is as simple as
something with duration
and grouping by the span name.
Ordering by the
cumulative duration
allows us to quickly
identify the heavy hitters.
The top two are interesting
for the rest of these spans,
and we can clearly see MySQL
dominates followed by Redis.
We can further summarize
by database type
to see the cumulative
MySQL in Redis times.
In this service,
we also tag spans
with the time spent in garbage
collection, which we can then
extract and summarize.
We're interested to know
whether GC dominates any
of the expensive operations.
In fact, it doesn't.
It accounts for less than 1%
of time spent in MySQL spans
and a little over 4% of
overall request time.
Alternatively, we can
look at the contribution
of different SQL queries.
In this service, we
tag MySQL query spans
with a digest of the
query template, which
makes it easy for us
to aggregate spans,
and then we can
search for examples
and find the actual
queries in another tag.
Here we see one query
clearly dominates.
Finally, in the same way
we did with controllers,
we can analyze request rate
and duration by arbitrary tags.
This is a request count by zone.
And this is a P95
duration by zone.
We can see some
small differences,
but nothing especially exciting.
If we instead look at cache
hit versus misperformance,
we can see a more
distinct difference.
And we can see
that our cache hit
rate is reasonable at over 96%.
I hope that's given
you a taste of some
of the types of analyses
that you can perform over
trace data using BigQuery.
The key elements are
getting trace data
into BigQuery, which you can
accomplish with Cloud Trace
Export, then extracting
interesting traces
to a separate table, typically
based on a time window.
This helps to
control query costs
and greatly increases
responsiveness.
And finally, it's
extremely helpful
to have a tool to view
the query results.
At Shopify, we use
Mode Analytics,
but there are many other tools
that integrate with BigQuery.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: Thank
you, Francis, and thank you
all for joining.
Please feel free to reach out
for follow up, and as always,
visit as a cloud.google.com.